the Joe Rogan experience it's it is a
weird you we all kind of become like
two-dimensional abstractions online yes
so I had friends that I waited tables
with and then what happened to me kind
of getting caught in the crossfire of
the culture wars is that I just noticed
I wasn't saying things that I wanted to
say and I was like why aren't I tweeting
these things it was weird to me Mike huh
that's weird why am i self censoring and
then I realized because it was and then
once I started saying those things
there's like oh this is why I'm not
saying yes I want to get in the war but
I didn't even know the war was going on
I was always going I was an idiot I was
drunk
waitressing and I put my head up in 2015
it was like there's a war controversial
opinion controversial opinions is always
a war and you know on the flip side of
it there's certain people who want to
believe the official story about
everything and they're just as annoying
as the people that want to believe every
conspiracy I was not aware that the war
included controversial opinions like
boys and girls are different
I didn't know that the thing had gone
the war had new rules and some Michael
mousers gives me [ __ ] like when I was on
as [ __ ] ass cuz I've been doing all this
when you start kind of speaking out
against the left you end up on
right-wing media because they're the
only people who have a conversation with
you and so yeah it's crazy so I go on
like Glenn Beck and I'm like did you
know that the left has different rules
for themselves and he's like yeah no
[ __ ] first
yeah we knew that we've been aware of
this and I'm just like this [ __ ] is
like can you believe these bandits
deeply entrenched in that culture war
you wouldn't understand how far it's
gone and I was like literally just
getting high waiting tables trying to
make jokes trying to maybe get some of
that TV money sell show and and like
trying to pay my bills every single
month
this past February is the first time
since I was 17 that I knew how I was
gonna pay two months of bills like
that's a long time to be
thank you I have some friends that are
blissfully unaware and occasionally I'll
send them things like I have a friend of
mine and I was sending this article
about all these different track and
field events that are being won by men
now Oh God any women not only that men
that identify as women but you know that
like in some places you don't even have
to take hormones all I have to do is
identify oh no way yes way high school
kids like you can't force them to take
hormones all they have to do is identify
as a woman is different everywhere
because no one knows what the [ __ ] is
going on so there's all these different
rules everywhere you go I was getting my
eyebrows done and my the woman who does
my eyebrows is Vietnamese and she was
telling me that her kids got their ears
pierced and she's like oh I went and
like my the kids they got their ears
pierced and my daughter who's not 16 yet
wanted one in the like year top of her
earlobe and the guy was like oh no she
has to be 16 to do that and I was like
yeah yet she can take hormones to like
it oh how they look the youngest of kids
ever an article about this guy who's
losing custody of his son because he
wouldn't let his son transition at six
his son went to his wife and the wife in
him split up and the wife wanted to
chemically castrate the boy and give him
hormone blockers because she had decided
that the boy was a girl whether or not
the boy decided or not they still we're
talking about a young kid and the guy
was being ordered by the state that he
had to refer anyway I don't believe it
was California
he didn't refer to the boy as a girl and
he had to and he was gonna have only
supervised custody now because he wasn't
referring to he was not allowed to
misgender his son his son was no longer
his son was now a girl well here's the
thing about all that [ __ ] it's like no
one wants to fight against the mob of
the left but no one there's no
established science on any of this stuff
and everyone's different I mean are
people that are trans yeah for sure of
course are there young people that
so that they're a girl from the time
that they're young and they're in
trapped in a boy's body there's so many
of them to say they are I would be an
[ __ ] to deny that right but how what
do we know about this how much do we
know about this and how much should we
interfere with their hormone or hormonal
development well it's so important to
like brain functioning isn't it this is
that brain development and don't you
change your hump day men if you're a if
you leave them alone they just become
gay man I've seen this online there's
like a lot of pushback from some
communities saying that it's very anti
woman and homophobic that a lot of these
things are kind of a rate it's like just
a woman is the competition well that
ain't and also just like I can't you
know sometimes you'll see examples of
women can't talk about their periods or
something because it makes like a trans
woman feel bad or if you you know so
there's this a ratio of like me being
able to talk about something because
it's it's like that's weird to me too I
should be able to talk about my
experience as a woman and you're ruining
the experience for trans people but see
that all just it's all about compliance
I mean that's what most of this about
all these nut bags are achieving they're
tweeting twelve hours a day
it's about compliance I mean most of
what they're doing is trying to get
there's one that I tweeted the other day
over and over and over again in all caps
she wrote any gender can have their
period any gender can I'm not playing
this game this is where I draw the line
I know that we just got demonetized but
I said it was over oh I'm not I can't
there that's the thing I'm like do
whatever you [ __ ] want I wanted to be
a turtle when I was like sex yeah or a
real turtle like live in the service
know that our turtles live in sewers I
wanted to be like a sea turtle like a
ninja turn no I wanted to be like a
turtle in the Bahamas I didn't
even though there's a difference in a
turtle and a tortoise until I was thirty
oh I know I don't I don't think I was
aware that different name for turtles
turtle in a water turtle they're all
[ __ ] Turtles I don't know anything
really and so that's the beauty ones
lived like hundreds of years TARDIS or
sea turtles do too though oh I think so
yeah but there's tortoises in Joshua
Tree oh yeah right yeah yeah they're
tortoises they tag I want to be a ranger
today therefore when you trip him
[Applause]